[Music]
i think we have a football team that can
go on the road to a tough environment
and and get a win um
i think that this was an opportunity we
we missed and
uh it's disappointing but um
you know i think tonight we were able to
uh
at least show a resilience and and
you're gonna need that to be able to uh
you know win in december and then if you
do take care of business in december we
have i believe four games left
uh if you do take care of business then
you know you get a chance in january and
that's really what we want to do
but not as good of a chance as they
would have had in january because
they're not going to win the division
now barring a loss or two by the packers
in games they will be favored and all
the packers have to do is win their
three remaining games not against the
vikings and they win the division
they'll be favored in all three of them
it's washington it's the bears and it's
the lions but
chris for as well as kirk cousins played
last night and he played well i'm giving
him his praise yes my my lingering
concern continues to be right what do
you do
with the game on the line and the game
was on the line with two and a half
minutes to play fourth and three from
their own 42. and it all happened so
fast it all happened so quickly and i
understand he lacks the mobility to run
away from the pressure
and and buy time with his feet he's got
to make a quick decision this was not
the decision to make don't throw it to
irv smith there i know he wears 84. that
doesn't make him randy moss he wasn't
open it was a bad throw it didn't even
have a chance and i got stats to back me
up here courtesy of the nfl's next gen
stats account sure erv smith
targeting him on that play had a 43.2
completion probability at the moment
cousins threw the ball it also had a
25.8 percent interception possibility
right the guy who was open was alexander
madison he leaked out of the backfield
89.9
completion probability and the expected
gain 5.6 yards according to next-gen
stats would have gotten the first down
yeah throw it to madison and i just
wonder if it had been cook would he have
thrown it right or was he gonna was he
concerned the rookie maybe gonna you
know uh do something down his leg in
that key moment have bobby wagner
closing in on him and blow him up and
not let him get to the sticks right but
that was the move there and i when you
got to make quick decisions because you
don't have the mobility to buy time
right that's fine but you got to make
the right decision too when you're
making a quick decision yeah well you do
okay i get it and you know things you're
saying are real i understand that johnny
analytics okay i didn't know you went to
johnny
analytics school overnight all right but
the other thing too is all right so
first off the one of the the the a
strength of your football team is not
the drop back pass game we know that and
especially without adam thielen it's
been all about the play actions and the
bootleg so it's not a it's not a part in
the game uh where it necessarily suits
your strengths always that's not an
excuse i'd like to play that replay
again too now the play itself i'm not
crazy about it's the same play on both
sides i agree it's a gold rat on the
outside and rudolph is running the slot
out and smith irv smith is running the
slot out route right so they're all is
all that now the back is a guy and i'd
like to see the start of that replay one
more time because you're right it looks
like he's open but also at the same time
you know that's your check down that's
like oh gosh nobody's open and to your
point here nobody was open no you're
right he tried to make a oh this is
going to be dicey but i'm going to try
to throw the perfect ball on the outside
edge of his numbers and try to get it
and because of lack of mobility and
things you've mentioned which i think
you're spot on mike
you know
he's a little reluctant to oh in this
situation let me pull the ball down and
dance around and find something now to
watch let's turn it back again let's go
back again madison is open you're right
but wagner's there right it's going to
be a bam bam it's going to be a bam bam
he's going to hit he's going gonna catch
the ball and maybe be able to turn up or
he's gonna catch it and get hit just as
he catches it and maybe not get the
first down it's going to be close
because you can see from that end zone
replay for those on radio too yes you're
right bobby wagner i think if he sees
kirk cousins staring at the back as he
comes that way that's going to get very
interesting so
i'm not in love with the play call i
understand what you're saying though you
want your quarterback your quarterback
your team the minnesota vikings to in
this situation don't just take it like
make a play dance around you'd rather
him go down that way than just pull the
trigger on a pass where you go uh i'm
not sure if that was really the the most
high percentage you know completion rate
in the world
i agree with you it was a bad play
design it's a bad play choice that's not
the play for that moment but but you
know i don't know that i agree with the
next gen stats there i mean i'll support
analytics when they back up the argument
i'm trying to make i don't know that
alexander madison was gaining 5.6 yards
on that that's what i mean bobby wagner
was there the angle that we see
when the ball is sailing past irv smith
and you can see him on the ground and
wagner over in that direction he broke
that way after the ball was straight
exactly when the ball's thrown he's
right there and he's got he's got a
chance to keep number one madison from
catching it and number two madison from
getting to the to the first downstairs
but i still look
i
it wasn't it all happened i mean take a
l i mean it didn't work it's designed to
happen quickly that's the problem yeah
you got your two receivers stefan dixon
that's the problem right going down the
field and once once the outs are run by
smith and rudolph what do you do exactly
right back in what do you do at that
point when all hell breaks loose but
obviously i didn't like it because it
didn't work yeah but at the same time it
looks like it was destined to fail from
the moment the ball was snapped i think
i think that's really what it is it just
was the wrong play call and the wrong
moment there you know you'd like to have
a little more options or something that
i mean that's basically a play where you
go
okay i'm going to throw a 50 50 back
shoulder ball to stefan diggs up the
sidelines or i'm gonna throw an out
route to my tight end where you know
they're at play a defense that's it's
very conducive to be able to cover that
so uh they're not great options but i
think to what you're saying you want to
see you know aaron rodgers brady in his
clutch oh let me look around the
protection's okay and i'll sit here and
dance and wait for somebody to come
hoping for a sec
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports